is like going out to eat and traveling
yeah that's a good point because
if you bought a lot of garden furniture
for instance last year it's not like you
need to do that every month or even
every year i mean it's a one-time item
that
probably isn't recurring the way that
spending on services
is now in the past we've seen big big
differences between what people
say they're going to do and what people
actually do and i bring this up because
we also got surveys that showed
americans are feeling pretty confident
right now
how fragile or robust is that confidence
how do you determine whether there's a
permanence to that confidence
well i think there's always the
potential for shocks right in financial
markets but also in people's lives and
we saw that last year with the pandemic
so right now people are feeling
much more confident mainly because we've
been able to control the virus somewhat
the vaccine distribution has rolled out
um
to many adults in the u.s so that is
making people
feel better about like their prospects
for
working potentially going forward or the
companies they already work for
doing better um over the next several
months and that encourages people to
potentially feel comfortable
saving spending rather than saving but
if we see a turn in the virus which
policymakers are certainly watching out
for that could
change the way that people you know feel
confident so
i think right now we're definitely
seeing a lot of the economic data come
in strong as you said and that is
bolstering people's confidence
but there is the overhang of the virus
out there and whether or not we could
see
a shift in people's confidence around
the ability for not only our country but
for other countries to control it yeah
that is a really really important point
um i mentioned gdp earlier we actually
got an initial read of how the economy
performed in the january to march period
and it was pretty solid
up 6.7 in the first quarter consumer
spending certainly a big part of that
but also a big part of it is
corporate earnings based on the
corporate earnings that have been
rolling in
what's the story they tell about the u.s
economy right now
i think it's a lot like we're talking
about in terms of consumer spending so
corporations last year got very
conservative in terms of not
understanding or knowing where the
outlook was going to be
for jobs or for how people would spend
and so they got conservative
we see that in some of the supply chain
bottlenecks that the demand came roaring
back
from consumers in some cases faster than
many companies and economists expected
so businesses supplies were you know low
and now we're seeing big demand
so certainly we're seeing companies do
well because
there's a lot more consumers going back
into the market as we reopen
and as they feel more confident and so
that's a good sign for company earnings
and it's showing up in the company
earning uh last question to you peggy
with regard to the record 21
increase in personal uh income it is
pretty massive but it makes sense
because we have this massive government
stimulus and
a lot of unemployment aid in the system
what do we know about
other sources of income for instance
wage increases and how they're growing
well that's a great point scarlett
because that's something that economists
look at when they think about whether or
not
inflation will rise so up until now we
really have not seen huge signs of wage
inflation
or big wage growth but it's possible as
we do hear some
um we do have some reporting of
companies not being able to hire workers
back fast enough and we did have a lot
of turn in the labor markets there's
certainly millions of people are still
out of work
but there are a lot of people who change
jobs and there are employers now who are
trying to hire back fast but having some
trouble
finding enough workers and so whether or
not we'll see
wage growth because employers at
restaurants for example have to pay
more to get dishwashers or waitresses
back to work
whether that will filter through to the
economy in a way that's significant and
drives up prices or
inflation overall it remains to be seen
got it
peggy really appreciate you breaking it
down and of course we can look ahead to
the jobs report
for uh the month of march or i should
say the month of april i'm getting all
my dates mixed up
next friday really appreciate it thank
you so much maddie scarlet i'm so glad
you just brought up wage increases
because despite the
upbeat economic data racial and gender
inequalities have been
exacerbated by kovid next up bloomberg's
chanelle basic and romain bostic
take a look at some of the alarming
numbers
in the late 1960s the average white
family had
five times the wealth of an average
black family in the u.s
by 2019 that gap grew seven to one
today black americans hold less than
four percent of the 116 trillion in u.s
wealth with homeownership accounting for
a lot of that shortfall
it goes back to redlining banks and
government agencies for many years
gave out the riskiest ratings to
predominantly black neighborhoods
keeping many families from getting
affordable loans for their homes
or for their businesses but despite fair
housing laws racial disparities in home
ownership
it's worsened in the last 25 years at
the same time
the gap in home values in white and
predominantly non-white neighborhoods
has increased then there's the gender
pay gap
while economic disparities for women
have narrowed since the 1970s
the gains have been slow and they remain
precarious
during the covid19 pandemic women
particularly women of color
have been hit hard by job losses in
services industries
many women have been pushed out of the
workforce entirely the number of women
who want jobs
but say that they're not seeking work
due to family obligations
that's more than twice as high as
comparable statistics for men
these gaps have an impact on millions of
people and they take a dire toll on the
broader economy
bank of america says that with gender
parity global gdp could increase by 28
trillion dollars by 2025.
unfortunately at the current rate it
will take more than 250 years to close
the economic divide
meanwhile in the u.s alone citigroup
estimates that the racial wealth gap has
cost the country an
estimated 16 trillion dollars and lost
economic output over the span of two
decades
next friday bloomberg tv will take a
deep dive into money and equality
it will air at 7 pm eastern time let's
get you some other headlines making news
around the world
in israel growing calls for a public
inquiry
after a stampede at a jewish religious
festival killed at least
45 people it's one of the deadliest
civilian disasters in israel's history
and happened on what should have been a
happy day on the calendar for the ultra
orthodox community
prime minister benjamin netanyahu has
declared sunday to be a national day
of mourning and the u.s embassy in
moscow says it will reduce visa
and consular services to a minimum
that's following a russian ban
on hiring local staff russia imposed the
new limits
after the u.s announced new sanctions
and expelled 10
russian diplomats russia's top diplomat
sergey lavrov says the relations with
the u.s are even worse than during cold
war times
and tributes pouring in for south
africa's zulu region queen
manfombi duamini zulu who died just a
month after assuming the role
her husband kane goodwill's wheelitini
had been the traditional ruler of the
country's zulu nation since 1971.
following his death last month his wife
was appointed regent pending the
installation of a successor
no details of the cause of her death
have been released the zulu are
south africa's largest ethnic group
accounting for more than a fifth of the
country's
60 million citizens for the latest news
from your part of the world go to
bloomberg.com click on the addition drop
down right next to the bloomberg
masthead and choose your region
scarlett now coming up after the break
the perception of progress your
co-workers may not feel the same way you
do about diversity efforts at your
company
we'll explain when we're back in two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
discrimination is being called out at
the corporate level boeing today said
that it's fired 65 employees for racist
or discriminatory conduct over the past
year and disciplined dozens more the
plane maker also released a report
breaking down the number of people of
color and women in its ranks for the
first time ever
and it revealed that nearly 70 percent
of boeing employees are white
blacks making up six percent hispanic
representation marginally higher at
about seven percent and asians account
for
14 companies say they want to do better
to increase diversity but it's become
apparent there's little consensus on
whether they're making actual progress
according to glassdoor black employees
are unsatisfied with their employers
diversity efforts
so to give us more insight into these
findings is daniel zhao
he is senior economist at glassdoor
daniel thank you so much for being here
with us
your research posed a very simple
question straightforward is your
workplace diverse and inclusive
and the answer seems to be it depends so
briefly explain what you found
well we found that black employees are
eight percent less satisfied with their
company's dna efforts than their white
counterparts
and that's based on data from over 10
000
employees on glassdoor and so it really
points to
how black employees are less satisfied
even though
companies are now talking about
investing in dni more than ever
the thing is and we talked about this
with boeing white employees make up the
majority of that company's workforce
and also the national workforce as well
do we need to put an asterisk next to
your results because does your research
therefore underrepresent the minority
voices that are out there
well i think that our research actually
delves deeper than
what global averages will tell you so it
actually looks at what
black employees perceive about their
company's dna efforts and what
white employees perceive and shows that
there is a difference there
and it really highlights that for
companies you can't have a
one-size-fits-all approach to dni
you need to actually make sure that
you're understanding how
underrepresented groups in particular
feel
about the workplace and make sure that
you're targeting any action and
investment
towards those groups specifically okay
so let's dig into some of the
specific findings where are these dni
perception gaps
the starkest because you surveyed people
across different industries
and apparently black employees in the
accounting and legal professions are not
really feeling it
so the three industries of the largest
gaps were accounting and legal
travel and tourism and consumer services
i actually think what's interesting
here is that some of these industries
are ones that are poised for post
pandemic rebounds so in particular
travel and tourism
and consumer services are going to see a
large increase in demand as in-person
services open up and so these are
industries where there are going to be a
lot of job opportunities but there are
also places where employers need to do
better in order to make sure that their
employees feel like they're in a diverse
and inclusive workplace but i actually
think the most interesting thing about
the industry data is not
which industry has the largest gap right
now but the fact that these gaps are
actually
pervasive and consistent across
industries and really highlights how
this is a systemic issue
facing employers across the economy
right so
has it changed since they last summer
over time as companies
have started to slowly wake up to the
fact that they need to do more on the
dni front
so we've actually seen that this gap has
actually widened slightly over the last
two years and so that might be a
surprise
to people who have recognized